on poursuit la page de sport du lundi la
chroniqueuse sport du lundi avec des
résultats à présent et deux résultats de
football ce week-end c'était le derby de
ce week-end entre le S Guyancourt et Le
Chesnay malgré un penalty raté après le
quart d'heure de jeu les 5 continents
ouvrent le score par l'intermédiaire de
l'inévitable kokenzo sur penalty avant
de consolider leur victoire en fin de
match pour finalement s'imposer trois
butins Guyancourt met fin à une série de
deux défaites consécutives avec ce
succès et reste 3e de promotion
d'honneur à trois points du leader
l'Espérance Sportive parisienne toujours
en PH trap c'est imposé sur sa pelouse
deux buts à zéro face à Puteaux les
Trappistes remontent tranquillement la
quatrième place de la championnat enfin
en DH en Division d'Honneur c'était
porte ouverte pour Versailles ce weekend
battu à Melun sur un score fleuve si but
à 5 oui donc ils ont joué sans gardien
exactement sur ce match les joueurs de
Frank bentolina ont en tant que c'est
plus de buts que sur le reste de la
saison ils sont désormais cinquième de
division d'honneur et on passe au rugby
à présent c'était score de rugby hein un
score serré ça aurait pu sans essai ça
aurait pu en rugby le pays le Pr c'est
un le plaisir Rugby Club c'est imposé
sur sa pelouse face à l'Union sportive
pitiérienne sur le score de 28 à 22 les
joueurs de Philibert ont inscrit 4
essais et ont glané leur premier point
de bonus offensif de la saison mais ils
se sont fait peur en fin de rencontre je
vous propose d'ailleurs d'écouter à ce
sujet l'entraîneur plaisir what flipper
au micro de Patrick Jacques de Dixmude
un certain moment on tenait la partie
largement et que on aurait pu enfoncer
le clou beaucoup plus fermement à ce
moment-là quoi et on sort un peu du
match on fait beaucoup de fautes contre
une équipe avec un moteur qui a vraiment
un super coup de pied on s'est retrouvé
tout de suite avec l'adversaire très
proche et du coup on a eu peur on a eu
peur sur la fin de match parce qu'on
essa transformer les remettait devant on
poursuit avec le tennis et une nouvelle
défaite pour plaisir oui le Tennis Club
de plaisir qui est en championnat de
France cette année en division 1a samedi
les hommes se sont inclinés 4 points à
deux face à Marignane et ce malgré une
belle perfe de Marco radou à 30 et
dimanche les femmes n'ont rien pu faire
face à Grenoble gros club de l'Hexagone
des fêtes 5 à 1 la lutte pour le
maintien s'avère très très compliqué
désormais d'une défaite à une autre on
quitte plaisir on part à trappe on
quitte le tennis on passe au basket et
on va commencer par les hommes les
Trappistes les toiles des cheminots trap
les saisons se suivent et se ressemblent
malheureusement ils se sont inclinés à
domicile face à Angers 76 à 58 l'étoile
les cheminots restent lanterne rouge de
Nationale 2 avec deux victoires
seulement en neufs journée du côté des
femmes l'entente le Chenet Versailles
qu'on avait suivi en ce début de saison
et bien ça rigole toujours les féminines
l'ont encore emporté naturellement sur
le parquet du Poinçonnet 54 à 44
évidemment toujours invaincu évidemment
toujours leader de National 2 après 9
journée et on termine avec quel escrime
c'est du côté de Trappes oui les
escrimeurs un très très bon club de
d'escrime dont on avait suivi les jeunes
champions de France junior ou de cette
saison ils ont ils entame parfaitement
leur saison avec une victoire dans les
matchs par équipe l'équipe senior
composé notamment deux Benoît journée
Cédric Kenney c'est un posé face à
Issy-les-Moulineaux 45 touches à 32
merci Anthony avant de passer aux
dernières invité du 26 novembre de cette
édition du 7 8 on va parler prévention
routière on va revenir sur cette équipe
on dit à Élancourt en tennis de table en
tennis de table à Élancourt on connaît
bien l'équipe féminine qui évolue en Pro
B mais quelques tables plus loin
s'entraînent désormais les pongistes
handisport autour de Florence sirogoscio
la tête paralympique qui a participé au
jeu au jeu de Londres notamment une
section à part entière qui fonctionne
désormais à plein régime cette saison et
j'ai eu la chance cette semaine de
suivre un de leurs entraînements
il y a encore quelques mois Florence
Sirault devait se sentir bien seul
obligé de s'entraîner avec les pongistes
valides depuis la section handisport de
cet été a bien grandi et compte
désormais cette licencier tout commence
il y a deux ans et demi alors qu'il
prépare son diplôme d'entraîneur Clément
Gadea se tourne vers la tête par
olympique et le tennis de table en sport
entraîneur de joueurs valides au départ
il découvre alors une autre facette de
son métier est-ce qu'il va être un peu
différent ça va être l'adaptation au
handicap une personne qui va être
tétraplégique ne pourra pas avoir une
rotation de bassin alors qu'un balise va
pouvoir le faire donc va falloir
s'adapter avec le handicap tiens je peux
pas me déplacer tiens je vais essayer de
bouger un peu plus avec mon bras je peux
pas utiliser mes abdos je vais essayer
de jouer un peu plus avec les épaules
cette approche personnaliste très vite
le jeu de chaque joueur un style basé
sur le déplacement pour les joueurs de
petite taille comme le jeune Alexis
d'agent ou plutôt sur l'avant-bras pour
les joueurs en fauteuil
donc je suis je suis tétraplégique je
suis obligé d'attacher ma raquette sinon
je n'aurais pas assez de force pour
pouvoir la tenir longtemps et
suffisamment précise pour les placements
de balles cela prend en fait très tôt
pour pas après sur la prochaine balle
être en retard désormais bien encadré
ces athlètes ça se traînent à 4
entraînements par semaine avec pour
objectif les prochains Jeux
paralympiques à Rio en 2016 c'est même
dans la tête c'est pas dans un coin
c'est dans la tête et ma préparation est
par rapport à Rio après je décrocherai
la sélection ou pas mais en tout cas
c'est l'objectif si j'ai rêvé c'est les
Jeux paralympiques de Rio en 2016